reenactment video alert let's see what
it would be like to get a facetime call
if don jr was your annoying friend on
the july 4 holiday trying to ask you for
money might as contributor gabe sanchez
produce an axe in this incredible short
play the clip
oh come on he's calling me again this is
a big one remember last year when the
white house put out like the most
patronizing tweet ever thanks to joe
biden you're gonna save 16 cents 16
cents on your fourth of july barbecue
now that same basket of goods this year
is up
ten
dollars wait is this some sort of
roundabout way of you asking me for
money again takes a lot a lot of 16
cents just ask your dad for money it's
gone what about your dad's fake election
defense fund it's gone all 250 million
dollars it's gone wow and you're going
to need to spend your money to enjoy
your fourth of july weekend even more
reason why i won't give you money one of
the greatest
uh certainly weekends for me junior if
it's for uh snow then it's a big no uh
you know holidays of this country
celebrating what we're all about and
what's that the supreme court stripping
away women's rights guess what junior
please stop calling me for money okay
you need to be independent
today okay goodbye so again we
considered hiring an actor to play don
jr but no no actor was necessary don jr
is just a parody of himself so he used
his own clip
it shocks me and i mean really shocks me
that don jr is viewed as an intellectual
backbone of the maga movement this is
the thing about maga it's just a bunch
of really out of touch really disturbed
people who let themselves be grifted by
the likes of people of don jr
i'll never understand it but i'll never
stop fighting to make sure that don
junior fan club is far away from our
political conscience in this country
thank you for watching please make sure
to subscribe right now to the midas
touch youtube channel thank you